I do a thing called clueless gamer where
I play video games with different people
and I'm terrible at them you and I
because this is your domain
you've agreed to play a video game with
me and we're gonna shoot it for the web
we're gonna play really Far Cry yeah yes
take that after the show yeah are you
nervous about playing with me you know
let the thing you should be nervous
yeah I've seen you play Conan you're
pretty awful I'm terrible I can't get
when I play first shooter games I can't
get that my character to lift his head
to see where he's going yeah yeah
literally can't
I kept trouble and then I start turning
around and sometimes I just turn around
I mean I basically act how old people
act in their 9 and my for me those
shooter games my main enemy is the wall
they should have a game for us called
get past your wall and out of that room
okay you have a new YouTube read
original series scare it's called scare
PewDiePie what's the show about
while I play horror games that's kind of
my thing on YouTube I react to them and
we're taking that to the next level so
it's real-life horror games you're
playing so this is real-life horror
games where you don't know what's gonna
have no idea what's gonna happen it was
most bizarre experience of my life I was
paranoid for a month and I'm so glad
it's over
okay so everyone describes hosting a
show